all right welcome back to the second
half of adam's um tutorial uh talk
um so i won't waste any of his time and
i'll just start things off um i will say
at the end when it's time to ask
questions i'll hand you the mic just uh
so that it's abundantly audible for
everybody who's watching um all right
okay thanks guy
uh can everyone see my screen
all right
so
let me just finish up with a couple
slides from the first hour and then
we'll head right into part two um if you
recall sort of the main point of the
first hour
was
studying this question can we find
algorithms that go beyond the csq model
or can do things that gradient descent
can't do
and we looked at this filtered pca
technique
as one way of doing that
now there's another way that we could
move beyond the csq model
and that is um
we could run gradient descent on some
very strange uh
loss function
so the csq lower balance hold if you're
running gradient descent on your usual
loss functions like square loss or
logistic loss
but if you
cook up something very strange
then for technical reasons
i can't necessarily prove the csq lower
bound
in particular there's a paper by uh gay
lee ma
that shows how to learn one hidden layer
neural networks and again it requires
sort of positivity of the coefficients
and condition number bounds but it
simulates
these tensor decomposition algorithms
by running gradient descent on a
carefully chosen
loss function they call this landscape
design so you're choosing the loss
function
in a strange way so it's a suggestive
that perhaps there's a whole
range of of techniques that we could
apply to come up with very interesting
and novel loss functions to get around
the csq
lower balance
so let's consider just the case of one
activation i know already we were
looking at these cases of one hidden
layer i'm going to make the problem even
simpler now i'm just going to assume
that the conditional mean function
expectation of y given x is actually phi
of w star inner product x for some
hidden weight vector w star and phi
again could be
relu or sigmoid
in this setting it could be any
lipschitz
monotone activation
and then if you look at the associated
optimization problem
which is you're trying to find the min
over w
of the square loss expectation of the
true square loss expectation of y minus
phi of w dot x squared
it's not too difficult to see that this
is a non-convex optimization problem
because you have the sort of minus phi
inside of a square
and this is this is non-convex still it
turns out
that finding a w that minimizes this
non-convex loss
is solvable efficiently in polynomial
time
and this was first observed
well i guess
there was sort of a predecessor paper by
kalai and sastry and then it was sort of
all worked out
by kakade kalai kanade and shamir
and the algorithm that they used what
they called is is something called glm
tron it's like the perceptron algorithm
but your so it's a simple iterative
update rule
but it actually finds
yeah it actually it actually finds a w
prime
such that 5 w star dot x is close to 5 w
prime delta x so you can actually solve
the case of one activation
and it works for all marginal
distributions on x not just the gaussian
distribution so it's
a nice
nice primitive to have
and even before that i think in the from
the maybe the late 80s
there's a paper by our herbster and
warmuth could be the early 90s i can't
completely remember
where they introduced this notion of a
matching loss
okay so you can take any
phi
that's
monotone and lipschitz
and they introduce this loss so you have
some candidate w and you want to know
how how good is w well this they
associate a loss function
among l sub d
sub s here
and it's the expectation over x y
of the integral
from zero to w dot x
of
the activation phi minus y
um so integrated over that
over that range so if you want to know
what the loss is according to this
matching loss for a particular weight
vector w then you need to integrate the
activation
over the range zero to w dot x
and what you can prove is that if phi is
monotonic lipschitz oh i see i already
had it written there then this loss
is actually a convex
and furthermore
if it's l lipschitz
then what you can prove
is that the square loss
is at most l
times the difference in losses
of the surrogate loss
one way to sort of see this
geometrically is just
to notice that if you have any monotone
increasing function and you integrate it
uh the integral is it's easy to see the
integral is going to be convexed
why will the minimizers be within l of
the minimizers of the surrogate loss
again you have to draw a picture and you
can
you can show that the function has to
always stay above the slope l
line if you draw the graph
okay so this this is a very nice
observation sort of explains why
that glm tron algorithm works
and it has some it has some nice
applications so with sperby oil and ragu
mecca we used this loss to come up with
an efficient algorithm for learning one
layer convolutional nets
and i think a very kind of interesting
open question
is you know is there some type of
surrogate loss
for one hidden layer relu networks could
it be the case that you can come up
with a very uh novel loss
whose say local minima corresponds to
the global minimum
of the original one-layer neural network
learning problem
i don't uh
to me this is a very underexplored area
of research i i just don't know the
answer
to it um
there's a very kind of nice theory about
this matching loss for but it only holds
sort of for one activation
so uh it's to be you know to be
determined
okay so this is the end of part one
although we'll get back to matching
losses in just a second so let me start
the second part of my talk
let's see
good okay
so for the first part of the talk we
were talking about
supervised learning problems i'm a big
fan of supervised learning
for most of this talk we'll be looking
at unsupervised learning so i know that
guy and salil will be very happy
in the unsupervised setting we don't
have labels
we just have in this case a distribution
some unknown distribution on minus 1 1
to the n
and think of n as sort of the number of
features that you have in your data set
and we get iid samples from d and we
want to learn something about the
distribution some structural property of
the distribution or approximate it uh in
some type of distance
for this talk we're going to be trying
to approximate the dependency graph
of this distribution so what is a dis
what is a dependency graph
so if you fix a distribution on minus 1
1 to the n
then you can come up with a graph on n
vertices
and this graph encodes the conditional
independence information about the
distribution so the way that we put
edges
in this graph
is you know
if i look at any
vertex i
and i
condition on any values of i's neighbors
then the value x i should be independent
of the remaining vertices
okay so any district for any
distribution that you give me there is
some corresponding dependency graph
could be the complete graph i mean
everything could be completely dependent
on everything else
um it could be a tree it could be um
complete if there are no vertices then
everything is completely independent and
uniform
but
the graph does encode conditional
independence information it tells me
again if for any vertex i for any
feature i if i condition on all the
neighbors in this graph then i'm
independent of all the values
of every other vertex in the graph
and the goal here the learning problem
is very simple you're given draws from
this distribution d
and you just like to figure out what are
the what are the edges in this graph i
just want to understand what's the
conditional independence structure of
all the features in this distribution so
what are the edges in this graph and of
course i'd like to do it using as few
samples as possible and as quickly as
possible
so this is
also called structure learning
so here's the brute force algorithm
we're going to want to try and do
something smarter than this
and that is
well i start with a graph an empty graph
on n vertices and i want to figure out
for vertex i what's its neighborhood
so i'm just going to enumerate over all
possible neighborhoods
and if it's a degree d graph
well then i you know it'll take time n
to the d
and for every
neighborhood for every candidate
neighborhood for a vertex i
i'll choose enough samples so that i can
look at some elementary statistics so i
can see well you know is this vertex
conditioned on you know here's my
candidate neighborhood
i'm going to take a bunch of samples
and then you know conditioned on the
values in this neighborhood is i here
really independent you know just by look
checking some um simple statistics is i
independent of the rest of the vertices
in the graph
and that way i really can figure out
what all of the neighborhoods are for
all the vertices in the graph
and i'm done of course
it's not the most exciting algorithm and
this is something that we want to do
better than
so there's a very classical and nice
result from
the 70s by hammersley and clifford
and it's a way to relate the dependency
graph
to the pdf of the distribution it's a
very nice structural property what it
says
is that if you have a distribution d
and you look at its
underlying dependency graph g
then the pdf factorizes
as a product of cliques
in this graph
so that is to say
the probability that z equals some
string little z
is the product of some function
over all cliques of just some function
of variables within that clique
and an immediate consequence
is that i can write the pdf
in this relatively simple form that the
probability that z equals any bit string
little z
is proportional to x
raised to the power sum
over all
uh
here i've written t clicks of 5 i of z
so 5i is just some function of the
variables in this clique
of z
and if all of the cliques in this
summation are of size less than or equal
to t
then by definition we call this
distribution a tmrf
okay so it could be uh that the t clicks
are very large and that you have an mrf
of very high order
or it could be that your uh t your
cliques that the pdf only depends on
clicks of size two namely edges
in which case we call those
distributions easing models
okay so these these are called
markov random fields of order t they
factorize in this very nice way
and as i said
one particularly important class of
distributions that we're looking at are
easing models
and those are the distributions
where uh you can the pdf is proportional
to x
of the sum over all edges in your graph
w i a weight w i j times x i x j
plus something called the mean field
which is just some
theta some theta i x i
uh some linear combination of
of your vertices okay so so if you're if
your cliques all if the pdf factorizes
and begins to size two
then uh we call it an easy model
and and the weights on the edges really
do encode
uh this pdf so it's just a simple way of
of writing the distribution
so what is the sample complexity for
learning general easing models
this is from a recent paper of devroy
moravian and redad
and what they proved is that if you have
a general leasing model with m edges
and n verses
and you take k samples
then the
minimax rate for learning with respect
to total variation distance
is
theta of m plus n
theta of square root of n plus n over k
and as far as i know
there's no efficient algorithm known
that goes along with the sample
complexity value
okay now the thing is
um
so so i think this is an actually an
interesting problem come up with some
type of efficient algorithm to
complement this bound
but we're not super interested in
general easy models
the the reason why is that if i have a
graph say the complete graph
um
and i discover that my dependency graph
is the complete graph well i haven't
learned that much about my features sort
of just tells me you know everything's
dependent on everything else
sort of not the most exciting or
aluminum uh limited
to the case uh
for the distribution
so a measure of complexity that we'll
take for these easy models is that we're
going to consider easy models that have
bounded degree
okay so we'll assume that the degree is
bounded by d you can think of it as a
constant if you'd like
and then it turns out
that
this is the result of synthetic and
wainwright
that in the case when you bound the
degree of your easting model then the
optimal sample complexity that you can
hope to achieve
is roughly 2 to the d
times log n
over alpha
where alpha is a lower bound
on the
absolute value of the edge weights
in this graph
more generally
if lambda is sort of the sum of the
absolute values of the weights
um for any an upper bound for any fixed
vertex of sum of the weights of a
neighborhood
then you can uh obtain about 2 to the
lambda log n over alpha
and this is sort of a more interesting
setting because it means that the graph
is pretty sparse
and
i'd like
to use just you know if you think of d
as a constant i'd like to figure out the
conditional independence information
um using only sort of order log n
samples
for the graph
so with very few samples i'm really
quickly getting a lot of information
about how my features interact with each
other
so that's sort of been the standard way
of
of considering
structural learning for easy models
and as i said there are actually a lot
of applications for structure learning i
mean the one that's
uh frequently cited is when you're
trying to understand protein protein
interaction networks in biology
there are um
there are many connections to
statistical physics and also to um to
learning kind of the hamiltonian um in
quantum computing it's related to this
problem sort of the quantum version of
this problem
and structure learning has been around
since the 60s when there was a result
due to chow and liu that
discovered the dependency graph
when you're
in the case when the graph is a tree
okay so what what let me tell you about
some other prior work for learning the
dependency graph of a bounded degree
using model
so typically what happened um you know
kind of 15 years ago is that
various additional assumptions on the
graph were taken i.e um you know two two
things that i've i've brought up here
something called correlation the
correlation decay property sort of
measures how correlated your features
are as they
as their distance grows within the graph
so there's an algorithm for learning
these models by bressler muscle and sly
under that assumption
and then there's an approach by ravi
kumar wainwright and lafferty that
assumes that not only is your
distribution coming from the easy model
but it satisfies sort of an incoherence
assumption related to the incoherence
assumption from compressed sensing but
but different
and then there's a very influential
paper by guy
from 2015
that
finally you know gave an algorithm for
structure learning easing models
that did not take any of these
additional assumptions so it worked for
general degree de-easing models
but the sample complexity was 2 to the 2
to the d times log n over alpha to the
fourth and so instead of getting sort of
the correct single exponential bound on
the sample complexity
it was getting a double x doubly
exponential bound in the sample
complexity
and then there's a
there's a nice paper by hamilton kohler
and moitra that extended guy's result to
the case of higher order mrfs
and both of these results
use greedy algorithms
so they define a notion of mutual
information between two vertices in the
graph
and then they use greedy algorithms to
kind of construct the neighborhoods
for the vertices
okay so before i tell you how to uh get
the optimal bound
let me just remind you what the sigmoid
function is maybe this comes sort of out
of left field but
remember that the sigmoid function is an
activation that we sort of mentioned in
the last hour that i didn't even bother
to define
but
it's this function
uh one over one plus e to the minus z
and keep in mind it's monotone and also
one lipschitz you know it goes to zero
on the left hand side goes to one on the
as you go to the right hand side
and
if you're really cool then you work with
tanges instead of sigmoids
um
like fred kohler always tells me it
shows my age that i that i call these
sigmoids and not tangents but
whatever
if you want to think of them as tantras
you can
okay so i want to show you how to learn
um graphical models or these easing
models using a neural network approach
so i want to use uh tools from
supervised learning to solve this
problem
because i'm preferential to supervised
learning
so let me show you how you would do that
um
so again the pdf of an easy model has
this nice form it's proportional to the
sum
of the weights z i z j and then theta i
z i
now i'm just going to switch it doesn't
really matter but i'm going to switch
from -1 1 to the n to 0 1 to the n so
i'm going to switch from the variable z
to the variable x
and i'm going to pick one vertex
say vertex i in my dependency graph
and i'm going to assume that that is my
label because we're going to do
supervised learning so x i is going to
be my label y
and then i'm going to condition
on the rest of the variables that's how
i've written x minus i that means all of
the values of the the variables except
for i
okay
and uh it's not difficult
to prove because we have this nice form
of the pdf
you know it almost looks like a sigmoid
just do a little manipulation it turns
out the conditional distribution of y
given x minus i is actually equal to a
sigmoid of w dot x minus i plus theta
okay so we're back in this case of where
we're learning sort of a generalized
linear model uh the conditional
distribution is just a single activation
and if i could learn this w
well that w encodes all of the
neighborhood information for vertex i so
if i could learn this w i would just
have the neighborhood for vertex i
and then i could repeat this for every
vertex in the graph and i would just get
all the neighborhoods for all the
vertices in the graph
problem solved
okay so why don't we do just that let's
let's view this as a gene simply as a
problem of learning a generalized linear
model just learning a single activation
and we'll run glmtron from
well this is the beginning of this talk
to learn w and we'll just read off the
edge weights
well there are two problems with this
um and the first one is the bigger
problem
so problem one
is that
glm tron uses omega
2 norm of w sample so
this is always going to be like n but
remember we wanted to learn the
dependency graph using with optimal
sample complexity we wanted to do log n
samples and if i just run glmtron i'm
going to pay
n in the sample complexity okay so i'm
in trouble there
now the other issue is that if you run
glentron
it doesn't find w per se
it just finds a w prime
such that
the sigmoid of w dot x is close to the
sigmoid of w prime nut x
so once you put them inside of a sigmoid
they're close but we're not actually
getting parameter recovery which is what
we really need to do if we want to do
structural learning
but i i think this is a another nice
example of why it's important to study
very simple neural networks just you
know even learning a neural network with
one activation
um
can do very sophisticated things it can
it can get you algorithms for for doing
structure learning for all you know
graphical models undirected graphical
models
okay so
so instead of running glmtron
um in 2017 ragu and i came up with this
algorithm that we called spirocitron
and homage to glm
and the algorithm is as follow here's
what here's at a high level what the
algorithm does you can um
you're given a bunch of examples x1 y1
through xt yt
and you have the guarantee that the
conditional distribution of y given x is
again equal to sigmoid of w dot x
and it it does exactly what g electron
does it outputs
w prime such that they're close
in square loss
but instead of using a two norm
uh instead of getting a two norm bound
on the hidden weight vector it only uses
a one norm bound times log n over
epsilon squared so there we're getting
the log n
and the the one norm bound is the proxy
for the sparsity of the graph
so those are that's the parameter regime
that we wanted to work in and so this is
the algorithm that we developed
i couldn't tell was there a question
from the audience i heard some mumbling
i was just asking uh if log n really
comes from being log one over delta
where delta is the probability of
failure and then you'll do a union bound
over the end things you're learning oh
um you'll see where it comes from i mean
not really it's it's it it's there's
another log one over delta because of
that but you can kind of
uh
massage it away
okay so the how does this algorithm work
well we use
a best experts approach
um so we're gonna use this very
classical and old
theorem
very beautiful theorem of freud and
superior from 89
and in their setting
you have these experts e1 through en
and
it's an online learning problem so in
each round the expert is each expert is
trying to predict something i don't know
whether it's going to rain tomorrow or
not so each expert outputs a value zero
or one
and associated with each expert
is a weight uh w1 through wn
and initially all the weights are the
same so you start with sort of a uniform
distribution on your experts you don't
know which expert is good which expert
is bad
but at each
round at each time t
that you know they're making predictions
we can start to see how good their
predictions are
and at each time t um you know depending
on what their prediction is they suffer
a loss vector l sub t so each expert
suffers a loss these are arbitrary
values these losses are arbitrary values
in 0 1.
and then freud and shapiro in 89
gave this algorithm hedge
that updates the weights of the experts
according to the loss that they suffered
and the weights have the following very
nice property
if you look at the sum
of all the weighted losses
that you accumulate for capital t rounds
then the weighting system has this very
nice property that the the sum of the
weighted losses
so so sort of in aggregate
is at most
the loss of the best expert so minimum
over j of the sum of the losses of the
best expert
plus
root t
n so here's really where the log n is
coming in
um
so yeah so as you know this this
weighting scheme has this very nice
property
where you know
as you aggregate all of the loss the
weighted losses of all the experts in
time
you're doing
uh as good as the best experts
losses
plus only root t log n so if you divide
by t
then you know
you're getting you know
that term is is vanishing
so this so this is the approach that
we're going to take
so our experts here so remember we're
trying to predict we're really trying to
predict
what's the value of x i or we're trying
to understand its neighborhood and this
is the kind of the label
so we're trying to predict this label
and our experts
you can think of as just the other
vertices in the graph
and so every time i take a draw from the
distribution i have a label which is x i
and then i have kind of you can
interpret the other
values of the of the vertices in the
graph as a prediction for what x i's
label is
so initially we kind of you know
well you normalize your current weight
value
and then the loss so the real
choice that we have when we're applying
this foreign superior algorithm is how
are we going to choose the losses i mean
they give
their algorithm specifies how you update
the weights the only real choice we have
here is um how do we update the losses
but you can kind of imagine
vertices that are agreeing with y
shouldn't be penalized and vertices that
are disagreeing with y should be
penalized and so we're hoping that we
can kind of hone in on the neighborhood
of uh a vertex i
and so it turns out that the loss
function that we suffer
you know what you should choose is
exactly that you should choose sigmoid
of the current weights
times the you know the vector of the the
experts
minus
um
there should be a thing here minus
uh the y value
and then you multiply that by the vector
x minus i
okay so we're really updating each
expert by how much kind of the sigmoid
of their
prediction differs from the y value
and what you know
why does this
you know
why so there are kind of two reasons to
see sort of why this works you know one
first of all you can just stick it into
the french superior hedge algorithm and
you'll get a regret bound that you need
but why doesn't this work for say all
activations where are we using the
property of sigmoid here
well it turns out that as you work
through the analysis
at some point you end up with a quantity
a minus b times sigmoid of a minus
sigmoid of b
and then we use the lipschitz property
of the sigmoid activation to show that
this is less than or equal to sigmoid of
a minus sigmoid of b squared
so that's really where we're using sort
of the lipschitz knits
of the activation but another reason to
think that this
might work
is that this quantity sigmoid of w dot x
minus i minus y
this is actually um the gradient of the
surrogate loss of the matching loss for
this type of generalized linear model
okay so another way to think of this is
that you're doing kind of um
you're doing a
that these multiplicative weights are
doing a type of stochastic gradient
descent um
and indeed this this corresponds to a
type of mirror descent
is it possible i mean okay so what
you're doing is sort of like
simultaneously designing some convex
problem and the algorithm to solve it is
it possible to just set up a convex
problem for this and then black box the
you know throw it into whatever context
optimization solver you want
is there some underlying context problem
that i can see
yes there so there there are two answers
to that um
well let me get back to that in a second
yes you you can just minimize a
particular convex loss just one second
i'll tell you about it all right thanks
okay so now
part two
is you know we ran this sparsitron
algorithm we got some w prime the
expected square loss is close
um we actually have to show how to
figure out that
that we can recover how to recover w
prime from w
and
if you remember the sparsitron analysis
it only paid the one norm of w log n
over epsilon squared and now in order to
get parameter recovery this is where we
end up paying
2 to the 2 to the one norm of w times
log n squared you have to sort of show
that you if you make this small enough
then because the sigmoid activation is
sufficiently anti-concentrated although
it's not very anti-concentration near
the near the origin
um that you can actually get parameter
recovery i don't want to go too much
into it because it's it's a little
tangential to the other points that i
want to make in the talk
um
but if
if you want to learn higher order mrfs
and not just easing models
then you need to use some um higher
order facts about anti-concentration of
polynomials again this is only to go
from the square loss of the glm being
small to actual parameter recovery
but you can do it
and so the bottom line is that if if you
do this
you'll get the nearly optimal 2 to the d
times log n sample complexity and you'll
also get a nearly optimal running time
of order n squared there's a reduction
to the light bulb problem which is sort
of
um
sort of a
kind of like a parity with noise type
problem
so you can't if you believe that that's
a hard problem you can't hope for better
than n to the 1.63 or something i forget
exactly what it is but but uh we get
running time order n squared
um and as i said
uh it's an online algorithm that will
work for all higher order mrfs if it's
an order t mrf
then your running time becomes sort of n
to the t and your sample complexity
becomes sort of two to the dt
now unbeknownst to us
uh well while we're doing this
there there was a result that it
appeared just a year earlier by the
frame misra lockhoff and chertkoth again
for just for learning ice
easing models
and it did get the correct two to the d
times log n sample complexity bound
but the running time was order n to the
fourth and the reason for that is as sam
suggested they came up with a
non-standard
convex optimization procedure and used
general purpose tools for convex
programming to kind of find a solution
and so they ended up with uh
with sort of a sub-optimal running time
but but they did have the idea of kind
of minimizing some uh convex objective
they call the interaction screening
objective
okay and there's been several extensions
of this
of this work there's a nice paper by wu
sangavi and demarcus that showed if you
don't want to run this multiplicative
weight update algorithm you can run
something called you can just run
l1 regularized sparse logistic
regression instead that will also work
and then um again vufrey mizrav lokov
and chertkov
later showed how to reinterpret
kind of this multi it's sort of
well-known the correspondence between
multiplicative weights and mere descent
but they gave a full you know mirror
descent implementation to obtain the
correct sample complexity and runtime
brown
and also give some generalizations to um
for other types of undirected graphical
models
and if you're interested in noise
tolerance there's
paper by survey and dan kanan myself
but i think
the they're kind of two
interesting challenges
that present themselves
after studying this problem because in
the case of easing models or markov
random fields
all of the variables that you're looking
at are unobserved are observed you see
you see there are no hidden variables
and there's sort of two directions you
could go from here you know
the first question you could ask is okay
well how do i learn undirected graphical
models when there are latent variables
so these are so called boltzmann
machines
and the second way you can move is well
i i want to handle the case of
continuous values on my vertices you
know what if what if the vertices are uh
are gaussian
and i have some sort of arbitrary
uh precision matrix including by
gaussian how can i learn the precision
matrix these are the the so-called
gaussian graphical models
both are very interesting lines of
research
just in order to fit in with what i
talked about in the first hour i decided
not to talk about gaussian graphical
models but i i would like to move in the
direction of
bulletin machines so i'm going to spend
the rest of the time talking about
learning with latent variables i think
that
it's a very
important challenge
okay so let me define
a graphical model with an undirected
graphical model with latent variables
probably the simplest model that you can
think of this is something called a
restricted boltzmann machine or rbm
and um i like to think of it as just a
well it is just a bar a bipartite graph
and the x variables on the left hand
side those are your observed variables
and the variables on the right hand side
those are your latent latent or
unobserved variables y there are
typically n variables that are observed
and m variables on the right hand side
that are latent
and then again we have this nice
decomposition of the pdf
so that the joint distribution over x
and y is proportional
to
some exponential on x transpose capital
j y
plus h transpose x plus l transpose y
and this j
is the interaction linux
and you can see that there are no edges
um in the uh
you know among the the observed
variables and no edges among those
variables
and we're again we're only observing the
x's
so
you know what we'd really like to the
learning problem here we really like to
figure out
is the two hop neighborhood
of
vertices on the left-hand side so if you
were to literally square the adjacency
matrix of this graph you'd like to
understand what the neighborhood is of
the observed variables
and restricted both machines have been
around uh for for decades
um i i think that understanding and
uncovering latent variables or being
able to figure out the kind of two-hop
neighborhood of the observed variables
when there are unobserved variables is
i think more and more people are
realizing this is sort of a fundamental
obstacle to succeed um if you're
studying causal inference there's been a
lot of applications in collaborative
filtering and dimension reduction you
can stack them to form uh something
called a deep belief network which is a
heavily studied type of generative model
and as we'll see there's some
interesting relationships to neuron that
works so i think this is uh learning
rbm's is sort of the i think sort of the
frontier for learning graphical models
from from the perspective of developing
provably efficient algorithms
right so so as i said um just given the
observed variables the learning problem
is to identify the two hop neighborhood
um or you know if you want technically
the two hop you know we're interested in
kind of the markov blanket of the
observed variables so the two hop
neighborhood could be smaller than
uh
the markov like it could be smaller than
strictly speaking the two hop
neighborhood of the square of the
adjacency matrix but that's let's not
worry about that right now and so the
question is what can we hope to achieve
well it turns out and this was
proved very recently in a paper by
bressler kohler and moitra
that
every rbm in terms of expressiveness
is equivalent
to a tmrf so an order tmrf
where t is the maximum degree of a
hidden node so it's not too difficult to
see
that
if you give me an rbm and i marginalize
out so i just sum over the latent
variables that i will get a mark of
random field the other direction is
quite a bit harder to show that for any
markov random field i can construct some
associated rbm
um and that's what they prove in their
paper
and they show that you know every order
t mark of random field
is
an rbm
um of degree t
where you have um
order n hidden units
and there's some constants involving of
the degree m here
that i don't want to get into
the reason why this is sort of bad news
is that
you know as an immediate
corollary
you can show that
kmrfs
actually encode k minus one
sparse parity with noise
okay so that means that learning
if you believe that learning sparse
parity with noise is hard then learning
rbms
um
you know you can't hope to do better
than n to the little o
of k
so that's
sort of a bummer
and so the approach that bressler kohler
and moisture took in their paper was to
assume that the rbm was ferromagnetic
and basically what that means is the
interaction matrix is non-negative
and their idea
uh was to form this potential function
um
[Music]
this discrete influence function
that takes a set of variables s
and um outputs the expectation of x i
conditioned on those variable variables
all being set
uh to positive
and what they proved in their paper
using the griffith german correlation
inequality is that this discrete
influence function is submodular
and furthermore the maximizers of this
discrete influence function actually
contain the two hop neighborhood
of any vertex i
okay so they prove a very nice
structural
property and that leads to a very
natural greedy algorithm for learning
the two hop neighborhood so again recall
we have this discrete influence function
and i can just you know given x i
i can pick
the variable xj
that increases the discrete influence
function the most
i can repeat that a bunch of times
and then after several iterations they
do some pruning to make sure the
neighborhoods are all of the right size
they basically throw out variables that
don't decrease the discrete influence
function too much
and um you know when you're looking at
when you're trying to gather these
statistics to maximize this discrete
influence function of course you may
need to pay sort of exponential you know
exponentially in the size of the
neighborhood
and indeed that's what happens they they
basically kind of simplifying things
uh they basically get sample complexity
two to the d uh two to the d log n and n
squared running time and this d2
is the degree in the um
uh
the degree in in the two-hop
neighborhood when viewed as an mrf so
but you can think of it as just sort of
two to the degree times log n samples
and n squared running time
okay so that's great
um
and uh there in 2020 survey goal had a
very interesting extension
um that generalized this to arbitrary
external fields as well as the pots
model for so for
higher alphabets
uh using the fkg inequality and some
properties of conditional covariance
okay so we you know still the the open
question remains how do we learn sort of
general restricted bolts from the
machines
and you know we have to make some
assumption
uh you know if you believe the hardness
of sparse parity with noise
there was a paper by bressler and buhay
in europe's 2020 that gave an
incomparable result
to kind of what you would naively get by
reducing things to an mrf and to the 2
to the s where x is the maximum number
of latent variables connected to the mrf
neighborhood of any
vertex but this this sort of leaves open
the question of what's the right measure
of complexity for learning restricted
pulsing machines i mean seem hard uh
ferromagnetism was one way to go but you
know is there some other natural measure
of complexity that lets us handle more
general cases
so
let me show you one possible approach
and again this is taking a sort of a
neural network approach to learning rbms
this from a paper with serbian fred
and if you recall for easy models
when we looked at the conditional
distribution on x i given x minus i
we showed that this was sigmoid or here
for fred i've written tange of w inner
product x
minus i it's a very simple a one unit
neural network
you can ask what does this conditional
distribution look like for an rbm
uh maybe it's a class of neural networks
that we can solve
and so it it you know it turns out that
you can start from this
um
formulation of the pdf for an rbm so
this is for general rbms this is what it
looks like
and if you condition
on all the variables outside of x i
then you'll see that the only quadratic
terms that appear in this pdf
are uh right here x i times you know one
of these yj's
those are the only quadratic terms that
appear after you've conditioned
what this means is that the conditional
distribution
actually is an easy model it's a star
where x i is the root and you have these
yj's attached to it
and it's known
from some
techniques you know applying some
techniques from belief propagation in
particular a result of mazard and
montinari
that whenever you have a tree
easing model the condition the
conditional distribution can actually be
computed using techniques from belief
propagation
um it's not easy
but what you find is that the
conditional distribution of x i given x
minus i will it's no longer just a one
unit neural network
it's now a two hidden layer neural
network there's a tange on the outside
then there's some other terms that i'm
ignoring but but importantly there's a
tang kind of run inside and then the
interaction matrix with the i row
removed appears times x minus i
okay and um these are referred to
actually as supervised rbms because
again you're taking a particular vertex
i you're assuming it's the label and
you're viewing it as some sort of
complicated neural network in the other
um in the other variables
okay but the point is that it is a
two-layer neural network with some very
strange applications
still
if you assume that the infinity norm of
x is bounded by one
which we have in this case because we're
looking at discrete values on the rbm
then you can actually try and prop learn
this two-layer neural network using
polynomial approximation
so we have a toolkit
[Music]
for learning neural networks
when you have norm bounds on the inputs
and the weights and there are a lot of
techniques that you can use for doing
polynomial approximation on say for any
distribution on the sphere and we need
to use these results because the
distributions induced from these rbms
could be quite strange
um
and we also applied a result uh that
sort of tant-like activations can be
very easily and well-approximated this
is uh from a paper of kohler and
rusteski
and so if you take kind of that
two-layer tange neural network and you
assume that well we know the inputs are
bad but if you assume that the weights
are bounded then you can get some
non-trivial degree bounds for polynomial
approximators for these function classes
and the bottom line is that if you
assume that the if column of your
interaction matrix is bounded um
the norm by lambda and say one norm by
lambda
then you'll get a sample complexity that
is exponential in lambda so 2 roughly 2
to the lambda
and the running time will also be n to
the lambda
and so you know if if you're willing to
make assumptions you know kind of norm
bounded assumptions on your rbm instead
of assumptions on kind of
ferromagnificity
kind of the structure of the rbm then
you can still
obtain non-trivial algorithms by viewing
them as neural networks and applying
some polynomial approximators
and in this paper we also give a bunch
of matching lower bounds based again on
on parity with noise
in this paper we also sort of show a
reverse direction if you want to learn a
neural network and you treat the label
the ver the label itself sort of a
vertex in some very complicated rbm
then you can use greedy type methods to
learn the neural network
by viewing it as an rbm
and again there we need to use
a ferromagnetic interaction matrix
okay so i wanted to state um for this
applies to both of the talks for today i
wanted to give sort of a laundry list of
open questions that i think are very
interesting and would give us
really new algorithmic tools for for
learning neural networks and graphical
models
so the first question that's that's
still open and and i don't have any
hardness results for
would be to learn rbms with just a
constant number of hidden units
um
you know do that in polynomial time i
don't see why that isn't possible
although i really don't know how to do
it
learn and you can see kind of a
relationship here learn one layer of
neural networks with respect to a
gaussian distribution
with a constant number of hidden units
that's also as i mentioned last time
open um and and i don't have any
hardness results for doing that um
you could try and learn sums so
non-negative combinations of k values in
fully polynomial time and k and one over
epsilon so try and beat the diaconucles
cane bound
you could try and learn deep revenue
networks with biases so a key
structural property that we used in our
fixed parameter tractable paper was that
they were all homogeneous values so we
don't don't know how to handle the case
of biases
um and then there's also some
interesting questions about smooth
analysis here what what is the right
notion of smooth analysis for one layer
networks there was
kind of a lot of progress made on this
front by this recent paper of velocity
tang and vijay raghavan
where
they showed that
if you you can smooth the hidden weight
vectors and use tensor methods you will
get
um
[Music]
sort of the best you could hope for
running time bounds in some of the
parameters but you pay for it in terms
of the smoothness parameter so they've
made some nice progress there but i
think it's still open
in terms of a smooth analysis for
learning an rbm or an mrf
there are lots of potential ways to
define it and since i don't have any
positive results
you know it's not clear to me what the
right notion of smooth complexity is for
an rbm but that would be interesting to
kind of develop algorithms in that
setting
then also you know what other
alternatives are there to gaussianity
for the neural network can we learn with
respect to distributions
that are derived from say an easy model
i think that would be very interesting
um
and finally
there's a whole other class of problems
that are related to kind of neural
networks and graphical models and that
would be learning generative models so
you could imagine that a random gaussian
seed is chosen and then you see the
output of some multi-output generative
model and you would like to learn that
distribution it could be in tv distance
or it could just be learning the
structure of the neural network that's
generating the distribution
the only result
about this that i know
along these lines is by wu demarcus and
sangavi and there they have a result
that shows that if you have a
distribution that takes a generative
model that takes a gaussian seed and
each output is literally the output of
just one value activation so there could
be different relative activations but
each output
bit is is the output of a relu
then you can learn
the the weight matrix up to rotations
yeah so i'll stop here i think i'm out
of time anyway
and thanks and take any of your
questions
adam um so any questions
no questions i mean i guess adam you
asked raised many interesting questions
already
there's numerous open questions that
people are already thinking about
so have you seen this work by garvey
rascotti in i think 2013 which was about
learning um
auto regressive models but on
on the on the hypercube so the iid form
of that is learning easing models
problem so there they use again l1
regularized logistic regression
and um on the logistic loss but with l1
regularization and they get a similar
rate but in the more general setting of
markovian dynamics and observing a
single trajectory of it uh have you
compared that with the iid recovery
results because that seems a bit older
than the results mentioned
yeah i'm sure that they need an
incoherence
assumption go ahead
um can you offer any
insight on like if you take a one layer
neural net and you train it on mnist
like you made all these structural
assumptions and you know the questions
what's the right one or set of
structural assumptions uh to make things
easy like can you validate any of these
assumptions if you look at simple things
you get from training you know
three i don't know how many hidden units
you want but whatever like can you
validate these with some experiments
well i didn't take any assumptions about
the one layer neural networks i mean i'm
not sure what you mean there
uh
yeah okay i guess i don't have
i mean
in the first hour for instance we were
talking about like non-negative weights
um or incoherent assumptions on the on
the w's like for the
for the neural net part of the talk yeah
i don't i think when you well nobody's
training one layer of neural networks on
on image on imagenet um but but
certainly
you get negative weights when you when
you train typically for a lot of these
data sets
[Music]
i i mean i mean and as you say you know
you also are typically over
parameterizing so
uh the condition number of that matrix
is going to be bad typically that you
know that's that's really why you'd like
to get rid of those assumptions
sorry i don't have a better answer for
you oh no worries one more question here
in the back i'll take a second to bring
the mic over
maybe not all of the results uh were in
the identifiable situations i know that
i think all the graphical models but
maybe not all the neural nets so i guess
there's two questions one is can you
maybe highlight which of the results
um were also when uh in unidentifiable
situations and second do the techniques
can you comment on whether
you get technical idea can carry over to
non-identifiable situations
yeah hey nazi thanks for that question i
think that there are a lot of results
for i mean depends on if you
sort of how bad the noise model is you
know whether it's agnostic or p concept
or
you know there are there
we could have i could do a whole another
hour on on just what happens with noise
so there are some things you can say i
would say in the
um for graphical models
the noise model that we looked at
was
for easing models was that each
vertex
is independently say missing or flipped
with some probability p and
it's it's kind of known
that uh
ins like if you don't know for example
if it's i think it's if it's flipped but
you don't know the probability p
then there are hardness like it's not
identifiable so there's some issues
there
um there there's also been kind of two
recent
papers
that show how to
um adapt to the chao loo setting to
noise to kind of find kind of find the
best
fitting tree based uh
graphical model
um
uh but but you know i would say i would
say for one hidden layer neural networks
you know in harsh noise cases
uh like agnostic noise cases i think you
can prove a bunch of hardness results
um for a single even even for a single
activation that turns out to be a very
interesting question
for other noise models like if you just
know something about
if you have mean zero noise let's say
then you can say for example all of our
deep reality network stuff will work if
you have mean zero noise
so it really depends on on the noise
model but um yeah i mean i mean
well also for the rbm results it's i
mean there it's not identifiable but but
your criterion for recovery is somewhat
different to go around that right
uh yes right
right
i mean we have to make a different
assumption there
there's a mix of different style of
results depending on
which circumstance one was in all right
well we're
coming up upon the lunch hour so
maybe we'll um end questions there and
of course feel free to interact with
adam he's a participant and we'll be
happy to
interact and answer questions by email
or discord or whatever
um i'll also be there later in the
semester in person
oh great okay so we look forward to your
actual physical appearance
um so thanks very much adam for very
stimulating couple of hours of
talks i think you've really highlighted
a couple of uh kind of directions where
there's quite a bit of uncertainty and
and uh open questions and a lot of
things to investigate
um so
in the afternoon we'll kind of zoom in
and get a sort of detailed view about
how do you think about that boundary
between what's possible and what's not
possible and what tools do we have to
think about that
so enjoy your lunch and look forward to
seeing you here in
just under two hours
[Music]
thanks again adam